yep okay okay can i welcome everybody to
this licensing panel monday the 19th of
october
um i'm councillor david german i'll be
chairing the meeting can i can i ask the
other two panel members to uh introduce
himself followed by the
the legal officer licensing officer
and the clerk for the meeting
counselor barry broughton
oh i'm councillor dylan butt on the
panel member
i'm lisa grimshaw i'm a representative
from legal services
i'm kieran hinchlich licensing officer
owen governance officer trafford council
okay thank you everybody um item two is
the application for a new
premises license uh brew chimp
strip with 166 barton road stratford
uh now we have the the applicant here
which is uh mr david lee
right that's right and you're here on
your own not being represented
okay and we have a representation is it
charlotte houston
it is yes hi hi charlotte welcome to the
meeting
thank you okay so
what i'll do is i'll just run through
the procedure
for the me for the meeting um
so first uh i'll ask the licensing
officer to outline
outline the application as we've
received
and ask the applicant to speak to the
to the to to the license application
um that will be followed by questions
from the committee
uh from from the representative and any
other officers i don't think we've got
environmental health here are we no
okay so there's no uh representatives
apart from um
from recent sites
right we've got that have we that's
right yeah yeah
i'll go through that in in your opinion
yeah thank you all right so
obviously the representative can put
their case and then
can be asked questions by the committee
and the applicant
um then i'll ask all parties to
summarize the case
for two minutes starting with the
representative
then the applicant and then we'll have a
briefing by the legal officer before
we we retire into a private
private meeting room to uh to discuss
to to make the decision okay
everybody clear about that with any
questions
yeah okay can i ask kieran to uh
to sum up the the application has
received please
okay thank you chair members are
requested to determine
an application for a new premises
license in respect of brew chimp
stratford at 166
barton road in stratford uh having
regard to the representations received
the requirement to promote the four
licensing
objectives and you do have a a secondary
matter
um for 164a
barton road the
following options are open to the
licensing subcommittee
you can grant the application in full on
the terms and conditions contained
within the application
to include any applicable mandatory
conditions or you can grant the
application as above but modified to
such an extent as considered appropriate
to satisfy any relevant representations
and the promote and to promote the
license objectives
or you may reject the application
a premises license is required in
respect of any premises where it's
intended to conduct one or more of the
four licenseable activities
these being the sale or supply of
alcohol regulated entertainment and
provision
late night refreshment the application
was submitted by david leap in respect
of brew chimp stratford
at 166 barton road the applicant
at 1.2 of the report you can see what
the applicant originally
applied for and during that consul
during the statutory consultation period
um dialogue was undertaken with the
environmental health officer
acting as a responsible authority uh and
the
um the following uh hours at 1.3
are how the applicant has amended their
application so
um this afternoon you're determining the
hours
as applied for in 1.3
there's also conditions which are um
laser detailed in
in the operating schedule reflecting
that dialogue with the environmental
health officer
the application was properly made and
all the procedures were correctly
followed the application has been
attached as appendix a
and a photograph for the blue notice in
place and the newspaper advert is
attached as a pendant
the premises is not currently licensed
so has no background or history
and the applicant has described the
premises as a downstairs property
in which currently in office which we
plan to convert to a bar
in terms of the operating schedule um
you can see from 3.2 onwards
there's a series of measures that have
been included and
some wording has been agreed with the
licensing officer
in terms of how that appears should the
license be granted
there is also a number of conditions
which have been agreed with the
environmental health officer as part of
the
um statutory consultation
um it's important to know and and i have
raised this with
your legal advisor chair that um because
of the timings that have been agreed
with the environmental health officer
uh the live music act applies and it
will make the actual entertainment there
deregulated
so it's only the the sale of alcohol and
the opening hours that are
being determined today that the live
music act is as
you're all well-versed ends at 11 p.m
so the conditions in the report which
relate to regulated entertainment do not
apply
um and that they're at 3.11
and 3.12 the
remaining condition agreed with
environmental officer um
relate to public nuisance and
deliveries and they're all relevant and
appropriate
should a license be granted today
the um
the responsible authorities in terms of
the consultation um
there was as you're aware representation
received
by environmental health i'm following
discussion of the applicant the
conditions and amended timings were
agreed
and that representation was subsequently
withdrawn has been satisfied
which is why the eho is not present at
the hearing
and there's also a representation
received from another person
um as a term of a person and that's his
appendix c
a copy of the report and all
representations have been sent to the
applicant
chair that that concludes the the report
unless you have any questions on that
at this stage does anybody have any
questions for the licensing officer
no okay and then i ask you just delete
to to speak to your application
in support of your application
well i think you're probably aware that
uh i own
a couple of bars
small community bars which uh we've
we've been operating
at uh earnestly for over two years
um we we get
real great support in the community
and we came across the opportunity to
to go to scrapbook because
a friend of mine owned the property and
another
[Music]
previously
the situation is slightly different in
that the upstairs which was
and nuclearly i looked at the previous
uh licensed application which
which didn't stipulate a great deal uh
it wasn't a great deal we've been asked
to do a
noise management plan we've already had
acoustic engineering out there
next week or so he's already given some
guidance
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
we'd have to ask you to speak up a
little bit and if we if we need
we might have to ask you to repeat some
stuff you've already said
because it got very muffled so anyway
carry on
um and then we will in the questioning
it might be a bit of repetition because
we are struggling to hear you just
a little bit so okay um yeah thank you
i pretty much said all i can say so
you know we we've we do we do really
work well with our customers and we work
we have a happy and safe environment uh
we follow all the rules
and i'm always in close contact with the
traffic
over over various things you know i
can't really say much more than that
anyway uh
all i can tell you is he'll be a safe
and uh community bar which which i'm
hoping
charlotte and everybody will enjoy
please please ask me any questions you
like okay thank you
um yeah like i say
sorry i'm just moving myself um we were
we were struggling to hear you
a little bit just to clarify that this
item too is the
is the premises which was next door to
what was the sit club isn't it
yeah so uh 166 is the store
and this is the grand floor yeah right
so
so what sort type of activities are you
planning for
well there for 166
yeah it'll predominantly be a bar um
we probably we do
some music events occasionally we have
the dj on
occasionally uh but as i said it'll be
all
within the the uh based on what the
acoustic engineer and the voice
management report comes back with so
uh well pre only would be operating this
environment
right so what what have you got directly
next
next door to you know there's the estate
agent isn't it under what used to be the
sit club is that that's still there
no there's a musician shop
to leave one side i get them in the
other side
right okay and they they
they i suppose they they work to sort of
normal hours for those type of
establishments
yeah and uh the above the laundry
is a an accounts office
and then obviously we we cover both one
six six and one six four
four first floor yeah but the separate
items so we will do we'll do the one
step
and then obviously item three is for
164a
so so what is the capacity for that
166 um
well based on the the regulations by the
durations
yeah okay
and there's there's no outside area
licensed is there
no no we're not quite so
what what do you use as a smoking area
um well as previously the smoking area
would probably be
at the front of the cycle
right um i'll just
so well would that be on the street or
around around the back
of the hollywood it'd be on the street
on the corner of the street right
okay i'll just ask if there's any any
other questions from members of the
committee
yesterday thanks [ __ ] ask uh the
diagram
that you've uh submitted does it's not
vague
can't sort of make out what's what in
there can you just walk us through the
the plan of that
downstairs yes so as you walk through
the front door
um the main seating
uh area small month disabled
access uh this is an existing wall
i could have gotten some pictures
actually but uh
there's a existing wall so so all the
front area is going to be a power anyway
that bit on the left there that's the
bar is it
on after the seat yeah yeah
at the back and those
those l shapes opposite uh a seating
yes i think that's the um that's a dj
booth or stage
that in that initial square we've
that actually slightly in that we're
going to move back to to the front
and it's going to be much smaller
because as we've opened up the space
it probably wouldn't work what are the
things i'm glad you you're discussing
this this point about about the
about the plan um counselors
just to draw your attention this is the
the plan that was
was submitted i don't know if you can
see that on the screen
if you've got a copy you'll have a copy
of the planning in appendix c of your
report
yeah page 33 yeah the
um it's worth noting that um
um the in the following on
report that you have for for the next uh
the next premises at 164a
what we have is cctv cameras and then
the fire safety
elements marked on that one and which is
which is often what we find with the
with the premises hearings i don't
believe we've received a different
uh plan from from you david but
the the the question there for members
consideration is
um is if you had a plan to uh identify
where you're going to put the cctv
cameras and
your fire safety equipment um there just
there just appears to be a bit of um
discrepancy between the you know the two
applications that you've submitted
all right um
no and it might have just come about now
you know
it's something that i've noticed and
that i just wanted to bring it to the
members attention
um well certainly downstairs we're going
to have
a total of eight cameras both inside and
outside
um so so with the one at the rear door
i have noticed when i've been cleaning
up in the back of us because
there's some syringes um so
we could attention upon the camera there
to try to
turn that kind of activity and there's
been a bit of flight up in there as well
so
so so um idea would be to have a camera
at the front
one at the side where the side door and
one at the back
which we probably got from the first
wall roof
so we can see on it and we can
with the uh
any sort of misuse of drugs and things
like that well
only because i've seen a syringe there
on the floor
i don't know how long i don't know the
previous history of the place
david would you would you be able to um
agree to to the to the cctv points and
your um fire safety equipment being
marked on on the plan for for this
application in the same manner that
you've
uh done in the on the secondary asphalt
of course yeah there's no problem
let me just carry on the emergency
exit at the back does that lead on to
the car park of the
or is that some uh back street that
can't it leads on to
canfield close right
and uh the
so presumably there's some kind of um
uh a point way
for being able to uh an emergency
point for people to collect or you know
an emergency where would be where would
the point be
probably at the front of the building
okay um i've not i've not produced a
yeah of course right that'll be with
application yeah and that
is that another exit at the the side
with those those rooms are those lava
trees there
yeah at the back yeah yeah and that's
another door isn't it
next oh no these are these aren't using
the front door
and there's the back door leaving that
one
so what's that at the at the back of it
there's
do you have any questions about
councillor brotherton uh
thank thanks chair yes uh mr dave just
to get clear in
my own mind i don't know all the
premises roughly but for 166
are you just talking about the
downstairs what was previously in office
are you talking about downstairs and
upstairs the 166 is just
downstairs there's no access between the
166 and 166 164a
the two separate yeah entrances
i know we're not on to 1648 yeah but are
we for 1648 are you talking
upstairs and downstairs well where the
sip club and downstairs are just
just upstairs at 164. so it's previously
where the sip club was
above the uh the uh well it was the
estate agent
i think i don't think it would be at the
estate agents yeah so it's downstairs
one six six upstairs one six four
that's right okay thanks joe that's just
to clarify me on my hand
thank you do any of the officers have
any further questions of the applicant
no thank you jeff no nothing for me
though
okay move on to miss susan's site do you
want to have any questions for
the applicant no no questions
okay um right i just
it's just a couple of things um
i mean obviously there's been an issue
previously with the sit club i know it's
not got this premises
about people leaving the building and
making a noise
congregating yeah the there's also an
issue with smokers
so the area that the sip club had for
smokers was actually just inside our
alleyway
which is next door to the living rooms
of myself
number 11 and i think it's number eight
so it's noisy it's smelly it's in
it you can't escape it especially in the
summer when you have your window open
so um we would request that that's moved
because it doesn't work and we did have
discussions with
i had a good relationship with heather
from sip club in that i could drop her a
message
or a text and ask her to move people on
or get them to be quiet or stuff like
that
um so we had a good relationship with
her
there are a myriad of concerns that we
have because this is two
bars so this is double the amount that
we had before
both in terms of noise people coming in
and out well
even so it's still double the amount of
people
and i'm presuming that the letting out
time will be similar for both
yeah yeah so all it will increase the
noise that the noise on barton road
bounces well all this is going to be
part of the uh
work that
[Music]
[Music]
whenever you're going to get the noise
management plan then are you in the
process of writing it
yeah he he took he's had the microphone
that we
at the front of the
report
is just based on making sure
we're working within the noise
guidelines
and that's that's what it's going to do
i'd say charlie's point about the
smoking
so you're gonna you're gonna move the
smokers are you yeah well we
i don't really see why we couldn't have
them
enabling well it obviously would have
been helpful to have the noise
management plan but
um we'll take advantage on that in
in in the closed session um
yeah well also it was there was a
reference to your
your um your premises in ernst
that you you've got reprimanded for
breaking covered rules or what was that
about
well somebody reported us
overcrowded uh during after the code
lockdown um saying that we were open
we were open and we were trading but we
were trading
as uh on shocker
deliveries of food and so
yeah they're correct we were doing it as
deliveries
and uh you trading us
um
[Music]
there's just one issue i noticed that um
you
you last hour for alcohol the revised
times uh
2300 hours 11 o'clock yeah also when
you're closing the premises
is 23 hours 2300 hours
so you you're not asking for any sort of
drinking up time
but what was that going to work when are
you actually going to call us
um well before coded
we were we'd originally
crawled our score was about two
finish drinking by for most people
and that that's the way you've always
got our instant books
so just to be clear you can have
everybody off the premises by
11 o'clock um
no i would have thought
well we need to arrange we need to be
clear about the timings and so what
you're saying is that last orders is 11
o'clock
yeah and you put them off the premises
by half 11.
yeah we need to make a decision
obviously on what what you're
what you're using yeah
if
yeah it's just that we need to be clear
about what we're actually agreeing on
um just just from a licensing officer
perspective um in terms of the process
of this application process that there
was a 28-day consultation period
and then now we have the the hearing
what was
put forward by environmental health was
a representation
um the representation was was satisfied
and withdrawn because the the agreement
was
uh 11 o'clock um end time for both the
sale of alcohol on and off
the premises and then the opening hours
at 11 o'clock as well
um so in terms of
um in terms of a debate
in excess of those times um just
just caution to that because um it would
it would effectively um bring the
representation
uh the potential to bring the
environmental health representation as
as a live matter to consider
and so just caution to that well
i think we better stick to that really
and make a decision oh that's fine
okay and if you feel that at some point
you need to make a variation that's up
to yourself but
if that's what's been agreed then i
think that's what we need to decide
that's clear enough for me another
matter that
they're cropped up and there's been a
lot of mention about a noise
uh management plan um and and i think
in terms of a concept it's it's it's
it's a very positive
concept and and david's obviously
um wanting to go ahead and get that
sorted
um there may be a bit of overlap between
the planning applications for the change
of use for planning and then also
also a licensing and for the licensing
purposes
in terms of the scope of this committee
and what you're deciding in this this
hearing um the the regulated
entertainment is now no longer
applicable something i covered earlier
on
in the report so if you're having if the
scope of a noise management plan
um you can have a plan that would be
considered for
impact of noise in terms of people noise
associated to the premises
or deliveries um or other issues that
that might um be associated with the
operation of the premises but if it's
related to
music then um the community doesn't have
any power
in in that regard i'm i'm sure you you
would have this
a similar um position from your legal
advisor in your delivery but i feel like
it's important to
to let um everyone know in terms of the
applicant and the
the representative to be to be
transparent with that
well that's fine thanks kieran to point
that out
could i just that's why we're talking
about deliveries and collections of
rubbish and but did does mr lee just
want to say
the sort of timings of when i think
you've already agreed about
uh the conditions about the not between
eleven o'clock and seven six seven in
the morning
that's right yeah to be clear okay
that's fine
all right um right can i ask
miss susan sykes to state uh
objection or representation please so
first of all to say if i can that this
is actually um
i was asked to do this on behalf of a
number of residents here
so it's actually not just for myself
even though i can only represent myself
it's actually because the majority here
are not computer literate
we don't get free papers we didn't get
notification of it it was only that
somebody pointed it out on facebook
i had a conversation with somebody it
spread like wildfire
um and they basically asked me
to stand in because i have a computer i
have internet and i can do this
um there are a number of objections
around
deliveries we've had while the work's
been going on and i know
i've texted david about this several
times um he's parked his van in our car
park
we've had skips we've had curtained
lorries with forklifts
we've had carers blocked from getting in
the car park
we've had deliveries blocked i've even
had the postman stop by
and say to me that we didn't have posts
for a week because he couldn't get into
park to deliver
and i have concerns about it being
suppliers
coming to drop off to the bar because
it's it's on a busy junction it's going
to be really difficult for parking
um actually using our car park for that
when we already have
a full quantity of cars that can fit in
there
it's a planning matter probably to be
dealt with by the planning committee he
doesn't actually
he doesn't actually direct directly
concern the licensing
objectives um so it's something that
need
would need to be dealt with by the the
planning up with the planning
application
so but yeah i do appreciate what you're
saying and obviously the two go hand in
hand to a certain degree
but uh yeah just to
just to kind of provide a bit of
guidance on i don't want to
take too much of the um the flow out of
the
the the representation here but um
just in it in in the similar way the
process has affected
the applicant and with with the measures
that have been put forward to yourself
and process uh and the legislation
around
uh organizing these community hearings
that they impact on
on the representators also um
parking um as you've mentioned and you
clarified already is is not necessarily
a matter for
the licensing subcommittee to to here
in this forum the other aspect in in
terms of i'm speaking on behalf of of
residents
um it is a case and i think it was
an accepted uh accepted point
but it is a case that it's um uh the
opinion or or how the the
um how the how the business impacts on
on the one individual
um here um and we don't have a series of
representations
and i know covid has applied but i think
the council is still operational
we we we are accepting that the postal
element
yep we've i've i've discussed that we've
um which is why i contacted
to query it because as i say people
don't have computer access they don't
have they can't print off stuff
they don't have any other way of doing
it and so and we didn't have time
because we didn't find out until
relatively late
um there is a process of um i've been
made aware that one resident is talking
about talking to the mp
and um somebody else is talking about
petition because
the other residents actually don't want
it to go ahead at all
they don't want the bar well i i
i've had a lot of social media stuff
actually
i'll just say if you have any questions
at the end then then
that's your chance to ask them if it's
the representative
chancellor so then you come in at the
end if you want to challenge anything
so charlotte if you'd like like to
continue with your representation
thank you so the um well i appreciate it
might not be everybody i'm aware of
one person i've been told of one person
in the second block who is quite happy
for it to go ahead and doesn't mind
and is actually quite excited about the
restaurant going in
um please bear in mind i'm getting this
piecemeal from other people it's not
direct to me continually um
from a personal level my issues are
primarily around noise
and um people leaving it being noisy
taxis coming in
them using our car park in the night
which basically means you can hear it
coming up and down the
car park um the smokers are an issue
and although the hours have changed now
which is much more in line with what i
would appreciate given that i start very
early in the morning and i know my
neighbours next to me start
at i think they usually start about five
a.m
eleven o'clock is fine twelve o'clock
was starting to push it too far
and we wouldn't get a reasonable night's
sleep if it happened to be busy that
night
okay thank you is that is that is that
your
your representation then pretty much i'm
limited in what i can do because
obviously i can only put across
my personal issues not the issues of
others
but that it is what it is and i don't
have much choice
okay can i ask mr lee to address the
issues you've raised particularly about
the
noise of people leaving and i think you
mentioned mentioned the smoking but just
just to
just to clarify because there's a
different hearing
i'm happy to take on board everything
charlie's saying um
things will impact if we don't control
them
again i've referred to the knowledge
management plan
we will have that in place uh something
we've got
across the two other apprentices and we
work
well in a suburban area
if it is a main road it wouldn't it
would
just it will just use an element of
noise anyway
which
um
and so so there's clearly a need for it
and because it was quite successful
and
[Music]
um
across the area and i think
i think it was actually only one
restaurant
you charlotte can i ask you did you have
these
problems when the sip club was open or
did you say i mean were you ever forced
to complain
to the licensing authority or not the
licensing authority but we went direct
to so because i had heather's mobile
number
um and i we were friends on facebook it
meant that i could message her
on a myriad of platforms to catch her so
that if there was an
issue so if it was a noise issue if the
dj was too loud uh because
the the gap between the two walls is
something like three meters
so it does get if the music is up loud
we can hear it and it
does get quite intrusive so we would be
able to message her and say
can you just turn it down a bit it's a
bit much
or if people were congregating around
for taxis or smoking or whatever
i could drop a message and say can you
just sort it out it's a bit loud it's a
bit much
the personally my primary concerns was
the fact that this was
weak nights to midnight and i work five
days a week at the moment i'm working at
home
and so it would mean lack of sleep it's
intrusive
it takes over and it means you know i'm
sorry i'm one of those people who if i
don't get enough sleep i'm like a cranky
toddler
i can't deal i can't cope and so i need
it to be reasonable not midnight that's
way too much
we've uh we have modified the time to
take you that's
more to your liking yeah much more 11
o'clock
yeah did you ever use the sip club yep
yeah i alongside my day job i
am i'm a blogger and a writer and i
specialise in gin
so um jane yes
you should tell me why
so occasionally heather would book me to
come in for
wi nights for a gin tasting sessions
occasionally we did something else like
a whiskey session or something like that
um and it worked quite well
there were no issues with it but i have
a personal license so i know
to keep an eye on people and get people
out when they're getting a bit rowdy
um so we had a really good working
relationship
um but we did have that i did have that
access to be able to say
it's a bit noisy tonight can you calm it
down
and because we are so close to it
because our living room backs onto
the city club where the zip club is it
meant that we could actually hear it
for our neighbors as well so whilst um
stewart on the ground floor
it would improve on him much more than
it would intrude on us i would still
call if i thought it was gonna be too
loud for him as well yeah
okay thank you i think if this does go
word i think it'd be advisable
for you to take david's number for the
well he's got mine already you've got it
oh well
there you go the two points i'd like to
to say those that already exist and
charles
haven't got
[Music]
bar is actually at 166 we're actually
uh building away from it now so
sort of noise should be left because
obviously and upstairs we're not
there's going to be a restaurant
in that respect it should be a bit crazy
okay can i i just has anybody got any
questions for the representative
at all and then
is that for uh charlotte is
just a couple of points one is the the
people that you're representing uh
i take it they're all residents in that
block yes
uh now according to your
uh letter that you submitted
it it doesn't really paint a good
picture of the sip club says you know
account inconvenience on countless
occasions
uh going on to late night noise
customers
leaving yeah and so we need to see on
somebody you had a good relationship
with
the person that was running it then we
did it wasn't just me that had run-ins
with her however and so it's that's
bearing in mind that it wasn't just
my opinion that i was putting forward i
was putting a forward words from other
people as well
so for example brent who lives at number
11 would have
issues when um heather would park her
car
in our uh the entrance to our car park
thus blocking it completely and moves
stuff in and out
of the door and brent doesn't like it
when anybody blocks
the exit because he usually somehow
manages to time it so that he's going in
and out at that particular moment
and so he would get particularly
frustrated with it
so i take it you're not confident that
the new
uh management is going to be any
better or worse i just generally have
concerns because it is a bigger space
it's effectively there's two sites not
just one and if they were both checking
out at the same time
you've got taxis coming to collect
people it's a very small space before
the junction
there's only the bus stop and then you
have the entrance
to our car park and it just gets noisy
as people are coming out they're happy
they're chatty they've had a few drinks
they don't have any volume control
and it just impacts so
you're basically saying that it's
because it's so it's going to be a
larger number of people
using the place yeah that's going to
make it worse
yeah that's part of it yeah
i'll see
okay thank you any more questions for
the representative
if not i'll just ask you to just sum up
charlotte your case of the
representation
can i just come back into a quick
question please this is for the
licensing people
were there any these complaints recorded
with the council i mean it says in the
in in her email that uh
uh that the council had to be involved
uh
on a number of occasions i think is that
right
there there could be i think it would
apply to
if it were the case it's not included in
terms of the detail in
in your report for um for reference and
you you have had the responsible
authorities
make contact and i believe the agreement
there was the reduction in hours
plus a number of of conditions um
but but also the the other part of it is
um
is that would be for a separate license
holder and not this applicant
so that there has to be um
in in terms of your decision making that
this is this is a new applicant
um and and it would be his history
himself
as an individual that the license
application is as
is himself as an individual so it you
you'd be advised against um
considering tremendous issues that that
could be the case from the sip club
and that's why you don't have any of
that detail and report from
an elect from an environmental health
officer or licensing officer
i hope that that's clear yeah does that
mean that
that can't be taken into account
i think the the difficulty is although
it probably did happen and existed and
was managed in
a variety of different ways for this
hearing you have got a new applicant
that poses no history on my individual
premises
so the the this caution into uh
into into taking any any other
considerations of
um a direct correlation between sick
sick clubs management and this premises
license application
it is the individual that's applying as
a as a new license and
there's no background history of history
associated to it
again it is smart it's part of the
process counselor um
and you know you can apply what weights
that you can but
in terms of any uh data and evidence
that that's not included in this report
okay thank you okay if there's no
further questions can i
just ask charlotte just to sum up
briefly the case for the the
representation
on the on the application please
if you wish to
sorry i'd meet myself um it was just
primarily concerns around noise levels
around the fact that there were going to
be two premises instead of one
um access issues which we've already
experienced
um and although it's inadmissible
um the fact that i was being asked to do
this on behalf of other people
okay understood we've done very well
thank you
um okay can i ask the the applicant to
sum up
this case for the for the application
please
um yes really um
we think we're we're going to be adding
to the community
and with the work that's going on around
stratford
part of that central hall we're offering
something a little bit different um
we've we've got a good reputation um
particularly about the noise
i'm not
so
is
previously
okay
does that conclude you yeah
thank you um can i ask if the legal
officer wants to give the
give a briefing for the panel before we
uh we go into the closed session
um there's no substantive legal issues
um i note the comments of the license
so with regards to what is in the um the
remit of this committee to consider
regarding the
regulating music and um obviously the
issues mentioned regarding parking and
planning
but um i think obviously the committee
are aware of that and i'll retire with
you
so i'm happy for you to ask me more
questions
okay okay thank you very much lisa um
it's alex there can he put everybody
into the uh
to the close closed session briefing
room
uh yes i'll stop the recording now and
then open up the
briefing